now in general the vast majority of
children do
very well in handling covent but as the
number of people hospitalized rises a
new trend is emerging with more kids
being hospitalized too
according to the national institutes of
health more than 1400 children are
hospitalized with covet across the
country
sally jeremiah joining us live from umc
she spoke to doctors
who are seeing more children arrive at
ers and be admitted
brian doctors tells me hospital rates
are higher
recently but they're currently not
overwhelmed although wait times vary
most hospitals have the wait times
posted
on their websites like these
it looks like we're in the midst of with
at the beginning of what may be a
fourth wave of infections
doctor david dijon from the kirkakorian
school of medicine at unlv says the
unvaccinated are now a major concern
with the delta variant spreading and
that includes
children who are basically at this point
too young
to be vaccinated because the vaccines
have not yet been approved for children
under
12 years of age i'm seeing more children
now in the hospital with cobit than
perhaps at any time
during the pandemic or just about at any
time
i have now even newborns dr jay fisher
head of the pediatric department at umc
agrees we've seen children
of all ages admitted with with kobe
related complications
down to the newborn period all the way
up to
teenagers those complications covet
pneumonia
and the need for oxygen the tough part
there is no vaccine available for those
under 12. if your child is very sick and
you are concerned
don't wait and don't let some er wait
times
prevent you from getting the right
treatment to try to see each patient
within
20 minutes of arrival it does vary
um moment to moment sometimes it's
pretty instantaneous other times we
have wait times up to an hour so this
disease
is serious it has significant mortality
and so again the message that i would
give is that vaccination
is better than disease
now doctors recommend everyone to
continue wearing the mask
when indoors and they say the only way
to help your child is if you're eligible
for the vaccine
to please get it reporting live sally
jaramillo 8 news now